hey guys it's Ilana and this is my
second Q&A this one is here to
celebrating 20,000 subscribers
seriously you guys a lot of people kind
of start to feel the pressure now
oh but for now let's question tap hey
you to the double oz it's a very common
question would you have a stream on
Twitch I think I might stream eventually
because I know that a lot of people have
a little fun with it but it's not
something that I would ever take too
seriously and that is because I love
gaming so much that I don't want to make
everything to do with gaming public I'll
have to worry about other people while
I'm playing games I don't I just don't
want to ruin my experiences really and
utila how do you feel about you being a
girl gamer and a cosplayer fine thank
you
I don't know what my chin that has to be
with it when you were young we different
than most girls with people at your
school or group of friends no I was
really shy when I was young because I
had really bad buck teeth so I would
avoid talking and we had braces to fix
those but I always gamed everyone always
knew I gamed a lot of my friends games
as well it was never a thing at all
maybe one or two times I'd be
passionately talking about a game I was
playing at a time and a girl I was
friends with would be like I just don't
even care and I'd be like yeah okay I
get it
whatever Eric Jackson 19 almost was she
like that up what a lens Oh Bioshock
Bioshock um I loved the first Bioshock
the other two not so much maybe I'll
make a separate video about to have a
board lands I find extremely boring Matt
Alex asked what started you off on your
YouTube career I would not call my
YouTube a career I started making
YouTube videos because I wanted to have
an extra portfolio for my professional
work as a presenter for other companies
so my personal YouTube now is sort of
just for a mishmash of everything that I
want to do for fun Pretty Ricky 13 in
your first video you mentioned your
skills in art I know it's skills out of
all of your artwork which one do you
think is the best and why so I just
started doing Commission's which means
that um people pay me to draw something
for them which is cool and my favorites
are either Big Daddy from Bioshock
or Mass
Chief from Halo and I think the reasons
these are my favorite is because both of
them the Commission's which means that I
put a lot more time into them Danny at
the end as asked has working in the
games industry in the extent that you do
affected how you feel towards playing
games and if so hasn't been affected in
a good or a bad way well Danny both ways
on one hand sometimes you have to play
through a game very very quickly which
makes you enjoy it less than you
normally would because you're over
consuming sometimes I have to play games
I hate and finish them which can really
suck when there's something else that
you know you prefer to be playing but on
the other hand you get a lot of games
from publishers for free or games you're
assigned to review that you wouldn't
normally play you have a lot of really
awesome experiences and you're forced
out of the box it's a very small
downside your name TIG asked what would
be your dream cosplay Tyrael from Diablo
II I just love the way that he looks so
damn cool Steve lab7 said she probably
did a deal nerds for subs or so much yob
asked do you enjoy your job I'm so
weirded out by the amount of people who
asked this question like are you kidding
me this was probably the most common
question I got asked when I was awesome
people questions and the answer is um
yes I literally have my dream job I've
worked very hard to get into this
position and that isn't because I don't
like it I mean how could you not like it
why would I be doing it if I didn't like
it
Jack suppose asks what kind of person
would you marry a gamer or a custom kind
I don't care at all of the person I end
up marrying is a gamer and I don't know
what you mean by custom kind what the
kind of person that I would marry would
be something that I'm in love with and
someone that makes me happy I don't give
a crap if they play games or not that's
a hobby not part of their personality so
there's that someone that I love you
love Chris show show us and you're going
to do an updated room tour now that it's
complete so a lot of people have been
asking me to do a second or two
since I moved house and have been
posting a couple pictures of my new room
on Facebook and Instagram and the answer
is yes I will be doing a second room
tour but I'm waiting until it's been a
year since the first one so that I can
actually have like a year of growth in
collectibles selva slide 51 asked what
colors besides purple have you
considered for your hair color I used to
have blue hair I had doc blue hair for
about a year before I had purple hair
um obviously I have blonde and brown but
next I'm gonna go red tough pony 13
asked any chance you'd come visit Canada
so a lot of people asked me if I'd be
visiting their countries and you guys I
would travel literally constantly and
would never stop traveling if I could
afford it so yes I would if I could at
Rue des gentlemen so what are your
favorite kind of video games whether it
be sure does RPGs or whatever bro I'm
gonna go with whatever bruh my favorite
genre of games is action-adventure
Mohammed is asked how tall you in
centimeters I'm 178 centimeters total
slash 5 foot 10 so my memory card ran
out of space so I'm finishing my video
on my iPhone here quality so I just
wanted to say thank you to everyone who
asked questions thank you guys so much
for 20,000 subscribers holy crap I'll
see you guys next time bye